-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS, CHEERS)
-All right.
He's an entrepreneur
and musician,
the self-titled solo, Michael
was recently released,
up for three grammys Sunday.
Killer Mike
is with us, Mike Render.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
-And he's the Republican
Governor of New Hampshire,
Governor Chris Sununu,
and she's the co-host
of The Five
-on Fox News, Jessica Tarlov.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
That's our panel
that we just had.
So, would you like to comment
on my editorial that I just did
about how there's a lot
of materialism in music
these days, and maybe
it's not great for the kids?
I think there's materialism
in American society, period.
Your-- your-- We're just...
Musicians and artists
a lot of times,
in terms of when art
becomes commerce,
is just a reflection
of where society is.
When you were talking about,
you know, it used to be
a lot of bitches and hoes
and homophobia in there.
Bitches, hoes
and homosexuals buy music.
At a certain point the people
who make music was like,
"It's not cool to keep
saying this shit
'cause they got better
buying power than just the guys
who are mad at home."
And what you see now
is the people on top
of the charts,
so the Kendrick Lamars,
the Drakes, the J. Coles.
Because society... Was it...
Here we say it, it's not
the vanguard that moves,
the people's not--
Leadership is when the people
are ready to move.
So, I think that--
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
-I think...
(AUDIENCE APPLAUD CONTINUES)
...when I have arguments with
Aniyah, my 26 year old daughter,
I know that
there's a change coming
because of the way
she views the world.
So, I think musicians
and artists for commerce
are going to adjust.
But when it comes to money,
we have an infatuation
with money in this country.
You know, so much to the point
we went and kidnapped
a bunch of people
four hundred years ago
and made them work for free
and say, "Boom, greatest nation
in the world."
-So, you know.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
-Boy, that's--
-Happy Black History Month.
Happy Black History Month.
It's like a relationship fight.
You never let it go.
-No, you can't. (HESITATES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
I'll tell you this.
Speak... speaking of money.
You want to let it go. Give...
Prepare reparations package
for this...
For this. For Black people
in this country.
-For people...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
And... And I'll... And I'll...
And I'll tell you this.
The leader of the feds
said something--
-Didn't I buy dinner last time?
-Yes, you did, you did.
(AUDIENCE LAUGH)
Yeah. And the restaurant
was pretty good.
That... That does not count.
You did off... you offered
to marry my wife
if I died early.
-Absolutely.
-But I do think this country
could benefit
from a reparations package
that included cash,
that included
reversal of redlining
by helping Black people
be homeowners,
understand credit.
And understand, Americans,
that if the Black community
has more money,
this country has more money.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUD)
-Yeah, and we need to start
seeing ourselves
in a relationship.
As long as we have the topic
on the table,
what don't you think
about that, reparations?
Vivek Ramaswamy just texted me
his Taylor Swift playlist,
I haven't been
paying attention to it.
(AUDIENCE LAUGH)
BILL MAHER: Can't believe
you're dodging this question?
-I'll dodge it.
-Really?
-In terms of what? Reparations?
-Reparations.
-Signing out a check.
-No. Uh, someone's gotta pay.
No, no, I'm not for reparations.
I'm not for that at all.
At the end of the day,
this country owes 34 trillion,
and the government
doesn't owe that money.
You all owe that money.
Don't be fooled.
The money's gotta come
from somewhere.
Is there a difference
between collective guilt
and individual...
-I don't want you
to feel guilty. No, I didn't--
-I don't.
Because I didn't do it.
-I think more Black conser...
-Collective--
But you benefited from it.
You benefited from it,
and you're still benefitting
from it.
Yes, that's true too.
So, my thing is
just help spread the benefits.
But... Okay, but, you know,
there are reparations
that do go on in different ways.
Yeah, absolutely.
I didn't say absolutely,
"Just give me a few million
dollars and I'm fine."
No, I think that trade
and higher level education.
I do think a cash payout.
I think that there should be
a mortgage forgiveness.
I think that
we should have an incentive
to incentivize Black wealth
in this country,
Robert Smith, Black billionaire,
had an interesting conversation
where he wanted
to tax corporations
two percent of wealth.
Imagine what two percent
of multi-billion dollar
companies does
for Black society.
What it does is it creates
a place where it's not perfect,
but Atlanta, Black people
have opportunity.
-And if you talk to...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
...Governor Brian Kemp
in Georgia,
Georgia, we also have
a Republican governor
who I have a relationship with.
For the last ten years,
we've been number one
in business.
We've created over 60,000 jobs
and have more jobs coming.
I would challenge you to help
put together
reparations package
that made the rest of America
look more like the opportunity
in Georgia.
But, he's from New Hampshire.
That's not gonna happen.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGH AND APPLAUD)
-But... But, if I may.
Lord knows I don't want
to get into a reparations
-discussion but...
-BILL: It would
cost you hundreds
of dollars up there.
And then you got the...
Well, again, is it,
what about the Native Americans
who are, you know...
You gonna...
you gotta go down the list.
And when we're done
with the reparation package
-this year what about
the future generations?
-You don't hear Black people
arguing against reparations
for anyone.
We've never argued
against reservations.
We've never argued against
any payouts for people
that America's wronged.
We're simply saying,
while we're at the table,
let's do something
to aid the people
that until 60 years ago
lived in apartheid.
-BILL: Okay. But like...
-Sixty years is not very long.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
With Native Americans, we gave
them the casino industry.
What about, you know,
supermarkets?
So, Black people
have the marijuana industry.
-Well, I'm...
something like that.
-(SPLUTTERS)
-Look at his fucking face.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Would you give us...
give us marijuana?
Multi-billion dollar industry...
-BILL: I'm not... (CHUCKLES)
-...it's still fresh,
you're still growing.
Why doesn't Killer Mike
have a marijuana license
in Georgia?
-I'm out of the business.
-Will you call
Brian Kemp for me actually?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGH AND APPLAUD)
-I'll call Brian right now.
I don't know
where his intention is gonna go.
-Brian is a great friend but...
(CHUCKLES)
-BILL: I mean...
If you're gonna buy marijuana,
I would suggest you do it
at The Woods.
Which is the great pot shop
here in LA,
which I'm the part owner
of with Woody Harrelson.
Okay, what do you think
of the news that NASA says
the moon is shrinking?
-Fucking Biden.
-(AUDIENCE AND GUESTS LAUGH)
-BILL: Right? Am I right?
-CHRIS SUNUNU: Right?
-Thank you. Finally.
-Yeah.
Finally someone's talking
some sense.
(CHUCKLING) The moon
was perfectly fine under Trump.
-(CHUCKLES)
-And now...
I was excited that
I didn't have to do
the reparations question
and then got the moon question.
(CHUCKLES)
Which could be more complicated.
Doesn't that go
in your headlines
that shouldn't exist bucket?
It really should. I mean,
but apparently, I read this too
in USA Today,
apparently the moon
because the core
is cooling or something.
-JESSICA TARLOV: It's our fault.
-(ALL LAUGH)
-CHRIS: Sorry,
why does it matter?
-BILL: It doesn't.
-Okay. Thank you.
-I know, but it's funny
because you really could do
a whole sketch about that
because we are so blame-happy
in this country.
Somebody has to take...
I think the moon's on Ozemphic
and that's the whole thing.
-(JESSICA CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS, APPLAUDS)
What do you think about...
(CLEARS THROAT)
...conservatives in Texas are
talking about...
Texas, well, this happens like
every two years.
This is Texas seceding.
-They love to talk about it...
-(MICHAEL RENDER CHUCKLES)
...'cause they--
they'd started out
as its own country, right?
For a while,
Texas was its own country.
We just had
a bill in New Hampshire.
We get it
almost every two years.
-Someone wants to--
-But Nikki Haley, your girl,
said she doesn't think
that's illegal.
Come on, she doesn't know
why this civil war happened
and she doesn't get that
secession is illegal.
Yeah, I'm not advocating
for anyone to se...
I don't think Nikki
is advocating for any of that.
No, but she said
she didn't think it was illegal
and it is illegal.
You can't secede from the union.
That's like number one.
-We're the United States.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGH AND APPLAUD)
I think everybody understands
that's what we need to be
and that's what we need
to fight for.
But Nikki Haley needs
a bit of a history lesson.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
That's broader
than the secession issue.
-Yeah.
-BILL: What?
That's broader
than the secession issue
-if go back
to the whole slavery--
-BILL: Right. I know.
I'm saying. She seems
to have skipped grades.
-I don't know. Some of them...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Look. Yeah. Yeah.
You want to end
this Trump conversation
once and for all?
You all get behind Nikki Haley.
'Cause that's how you do it.
You beat Trump
on the ballot box.
-I mean that's it.
-(AUDIENCE GROANS)
Look, politics is not
a spectator sport, people.
You gotta get involved.
You got to vote.
You got to participate.
You-- This stuff--
JESSICA: They could vote
for Joe Biden, though.
-AUDIENCE MEMBER: Yeah!
-(AUDIENCE CHEER AND APPLAUD)
But according to the polls...
But according to the polls
they won't.
That's not true.
They won't,
Nikki Haley beat Biden
-by ten-15 points.
-(OVERLAPPING CHATTER)
All right, all right, all right,
everybody, please, stop yelling.
(AUDIENCE LAUGH AND APPLAUD)
But the moon is shrinking, Bill.
-The moon is shrinking.
I'm shrinking now, okay.
Jessica, how much of damaging
could a potential no labels
presidential ticket
be for Joe Biden.
So, this is an official
third party now, no labels?
-Who is this?
-A bunch of grifters--
Joe Manchin. It says
what do you make of rumors
Joe Manchin
will be their candidate?
-Oh, exciting.
-(AUDIENCE CHUCKLE)
I'll start by saying
the no labels folks are grifters
and everyone should know
that they're just trying to--
-BILL: Grifters?
-Grifters.
-BILL: Right.
-Yes.
BILL: You think they're sincere?
I think they're sincere
like 40 minutes a day.
And then I think
the rest of it...
-(BILL CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGH)
-...is just an attempt to get...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
...people
who feel disenfranchised
like they're looking
around like they're two
-80 year old guys.
I don't like either of them.
-BILL: Right.
Give me more money.
-And they don't really care
what the outcome is,
and they justify it by saying,
you know, well,
it's gonna suck either way.
But, apparently, the top polling
no labels ticket
is Nikki Haley as president
and Joe Manchin as VP.
I happen to think,
and Joe Manchin
is not my favorite Democrat.
Though, he voted with us
all the time, and I'm thankful
for having someone
in West Virginia.
I don't think
he would do something like that
because it would just destroy
an entire legacy that he's had.
But they do take more
support from Trump
than they do from Biden.
It's the same
with like R.F.K. Jr.
If you were able to get on
more than half a ballot...
-BILL: Right.
-...or something like that.
Okay, Elon Musk announced
his company Neuralink.
Oh. This is a pretty big story.
Successfully implanted
the first microchip
in a human's brain.
Is this a good thing?
I... Yes, I think it is,
because I mean, this is,
if you haven't read the story,
the ability to actually
do things just by thinking
about it for people
who don't have the use
of their limbs.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUD)
-And this is, you know, I--
Look...
(CHUCKLES)
I can't stop liking Elon.
(HESITATES)
He's a weird guy, he is.
-JESSICA: Yeah.
-And he does sometimes make it
hard to defend him.
Absolutely, I get that.
But this is the promise
of a guy like this.
I mean, who else is doing this?
I can't even imagine
how this is done.
Like, I couldn't tell you
how electricity happens,
-but I probably could find out.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
It's a short Wikipedia.
(CHUCKLES)
But like how do you get it
so, like,
just by thinking about it,
you change the channel? Don't.
-But, uh...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...that's pretty amazing
and I think it's gonna--
You know,
there's lots of people
who can benefit from this.
Totally, I'm sure
it'll be used for evil
at some point,
but for now, it's wonderful
-to get people a chance.
-BILL: Anybody like--
-CHRIS: Just like all things
in America.
-MICHAEL: Yeah.
-Yes.
-You eventually use it for evil.
That's what...
-JESSICA: Goes back
to your money.
-Or sex.
-Oh, yeah.
-Sex is usually
the first thing
they'll find a way for a guy
to jerk off like just by.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGH AND APPLAUD)
Uh... (CLEARS THROAT)
A recent...
A recent study found
a growing political divide
between men and women
with younger women skewing
much more liberal than men.
This is not new, but I think
it's just more prevalent.
I think this--
The number I saw was 30 points.
-That is a huge.
-JESSICA: Yeah.
-And that's the abortion issue,
right?
-BILL: That's a lot of--
As Republicans,
we're losing young people,
we're losing suburban moms,
we're losing women
strictly on the abortion issue
and that's just...
terrible for the party.
I think it's abortion,
it's guns, it's climate change,
it's social justice.
BILL: And Trump
and that pussy grabber...
-JESSICA: It's Trump. Yes.
-...who's like...
-(HESITATES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-And now owing 83 million--
-I'm not with Trump,
I don't know why you guys
keep looking at me.
I know, I know, I know,
but what's interesting,
what you two have in common
is that you both can't say,
"Yeah, and of course,
so I'm voting for Biden."
-You both can't do that.
-I challenge you.
I just find that interesting.
He can't say, she can't say,
you can't say, Biden can't say,
and most White people
won't say,
I'll sit down and talk
about Black people
about real Black issues
from a place
where I know
I'm going to leave--
That's a different issue.
I'm just--
-No, I'm talking about
Repar-fucking-ation.
-I know you are.
Like we don't want to talk
about that,
but when you say
me and him are the same.
You know, what I'm going to say
besides that we want to do--
Like what? How do Biden
or a Trump make good
for my community?
-(HESITATES) That's it--
-And I'm not saying
they're the same.
But you got to meet me
at my table not just have lunch
with a Black kid
and think everything's okay.
At least you're engaging
with the question now.
-Yeah.
-Right. I get that.
-I totally get that.
CHRIS: Yeah.
Have neighborhoods
really changed?
I mean, I forget who I'm...
Well, last three years worse.
I mean, it's tougher.
Neighborhoods and what's going
with crime, with public safety,
with all of this,
it's just getting worse
and worse, and worse.
And both parties are to blame.
-Let's not make any...
-BILL: Well, that's the thing.
I mean, if you live
in a neighborhood
and you see administrations
change and nothing else changes,
that... I totally get.
Why you would go,
what's the difference
which White guy is president?
Didn't make any difference.
And a lot of people
weren't crazy about Obama.
Didn't think
he was the radical change.
They always--
They projected that on him.
He would never said he--
I think Americans
are comfortably...
they're comfortably
uncomfortable.
I think that this country
could be radically better
if we say it we're going
to do something radical
-and hold politicians' feet
to the fire on politics...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
-And we're not.
-Absolutely.
We're just simply not doing it.
And at some point,
we're going to have to
get off TV arguing
for entertainment
and we're going
to have to retreat
to our living rooms
after church, synagogues
or mosque functions
and we're going
to have real discussions
where we disagree
and agree and we find out
what are the ten things
that are best
on hyper local level.
What could be realer
than this discussion?
-(JESSICA CHUCKLES)
-CHRIS: If I could--
-Well, after--
-Don't be telling people
-to get off TV.
-No, I want people watch TV.
But I want people
to get with people
-who don't look like--
-Not TV or this TV.
Well, this TV.
I like your show.
I don't watch
most of you guys show.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS AND APPLAUD)
-(OVERLAPPING CHATTER)
I'm sure rappers
aren't rapping about it yet.
But I do want to say
that the discussions
that are had here
take to your living rooms
with your family members
you hadn't talked to
because they voted
for the other guy
-and have the discussions,
find things you agree with...
-Yes. I could not agree more.
...and on a hyper-local level.
What's more important
to Americans should be,
who's my city council person?
Who's my mayor?
And who's my governor?
-School board.
-MICHAEL: And school board.
If you do that,
I guarantee you
you'll start to create
local change
that then from the top down,
they'll say we need
to emulate that
and I'll give you
a perfect example to you.
A democratic judge named
Asha Jackson,
Chief Judge Asha Jackson
in Georgia,
creates the pinnacle program
that gives people
an opportunity not to fall prey
to recidivism
and go back to jail.
You get one year
to clean your shit up
then you graduate, you go,
you don't have to go to prison.
Miss Ali is a woman out of
Fulton County Juvenile Court
that was appointed
by a Republican governor
to emulate
that same thing statewide,
so two Democratic Black women
do something on a local level
that on a state level,
a White Republican governor
recognizes and then empowers
to do the same thing statewide.
That's what we need
to be seeing hyper-local,
instead of arguing about
the soap opera and president.
-All right.
-(AUDIENCE CHEER AND APPLAUD)
See you when you have
those three grammys
-in your hands.
-Absolutely.
All right, thank you, everybody,
we gotta go.